I got signed pretty much off of so when
I got signed I was signed to 300 ENT and
I'm assigned to QC records right and
then like so I have to like buy my way
out so I never had no hit so it's hard
to get a lot of money for my labor when
you have no streams so I had to I had to
pay QC 500 000 and I had to give 300 300
000. plus I had to get paid myself so
you can imagine I had a big deal signing
my first deal so you get the deal from
Interscope and out of that money you had
to pay off QC and 300 300 and I had to
get paid and you had to still take some
money home for yourself yeah because at
the time I was signed with QC and and
not asked Pizza like you know I'm saying
do my thing he's like I need 500 000.
and at the time I didn't have five
thousand dollars right you know let
alone 500. so I went in my phone
and I call everybody from every label
every label that I had on my phone right
you know and thank God I found one
person
uh Manny Smith I shot the Manny he's
like yo come to the office
you know and then it's history God
God did the rest shout out to I mean
thank you they let you buy yourself out
at least and they you know they believed
in me when I first jumped off the gate
you know what I'm saying for sure I mean
a lot of people kind of would equate you
to be like the fourth unofficial media
early on in your career because you're
on so many of those early records you
know yeah like me and Amigo were
dropping a lot of tapes and before
they signed to qc2 so it was just like
we just hustling and working trying to
get our music heard you feel me how
close were you from like actually
joining the group though
never never happened